want to go back to the beginning and ask
you about signing on for this film as an
actor evolving your craft what was it
about this role that made you think this
is what I need in my career right now H
very good
question um I would say the intimate
part of it and the profound message the
tale about the chosen family that you
create and um it was really appealing to
me I received an email uh from my agent
telling me about the project and
sometimes you don't even have the script
and you have just only signs and you
have to sign NDA and everything and it's
so complicated and on this one there
were the script so I read it straight
away and I felt in love with the story
and said I want to tell that story of
that so you read the script at that
point what is the quality of your
character that you were most looking
forward to playing but then I also want
to know a quality you discovered along
the way that wound up being more
creatively fulfilling to play than you
ever could have imagined at the start
okay great uh the quality I was looking
for or the aspect was trying to be
honest all the time uh how could you do
that so what Journey brings you to it so
that was the thing and what I
discover so many things but uh I would
say
um the importance of
time yeah profound yeah yeah so now I
want to talk a little bit about working
with Dan first as a as a director here
because I have high hopes that if he
wants there are going to be many more
feature directing opportunities down the
line for him so what is something you
appreciated about him as an actor's
director that you're excited for more
actors to get to experience in the
future the communication The Exchange uh
before the filming on the set uh is a
great listener uh is ready and open to
every
suggestion I felt like he wanted me to
be as free as possible and that's just a
dream you know not you do this it's
going to be like this just block here
and say it this like way work on your
accent no just feel free and talk and
talk and talk so we did a lot of not not
proper rehouse home but
just talks talks reading the lines of
course and exchanging ideas and the work
on Theo silhouett as well it was really
involved in all the um not fashion but
costume aspect and was really
interesting I have a feeling some of
that might answer this question as well
but I'm curious about working with him
as a scene partner too is is there
anything he did that helped you reach
something in Theo that you might not
have been able to without
him profound as well
um I think uh we had before the filming
thanks to the prep um an organic
relationship
so that helped me to be um the best
actor I could thanks to that thanks to
him sounds like he creates the best
possible environment onone FL I love it
honestly and he so sweet and intelligent
and smart and never in a rush uh we had
time to do everything and yeah a lovely
guy that's always the best possible
luxury to have on a set if there a
sequel I'll s it right away I would like
to see the sequel all right so so to tee
up the the future whether it's a sequel
to this or more for you in general what
is a new tool in your acting toolkit so
to speak that you know you can credit to
the good grief experience
H that brilliant question
um trust trust but you need to earn it
so yeah it's that was a very special
people and a very special project so
yeah but I'll I'll try to be yeah yeah
to recreate that trust with other ones
it's a good tool for someone to have on
their own but it's also an important
tool to be earned from Project to
project so both sides are important
there I have a big feeling a lot of
people out there are going to watch this
film and find catharsis in it so I am
curious for you if not good grief is
there another film you turn to when you
kind of need that cathartic
release I love your questions all of
them uh many but
um
oh I going to say the good one
so I would
say maybe a fun one sex in the CT the
movie I'll take that one happily yeah
yeah you know the marriage part and
everything when they go to Mexico it was
like that's a beautiful answer mine's
fun too I turn to inside out whenever I
need that kind of emotional release I
feel like that movie proc the Siri the
movies everything it's perfect perfect I
love it thank thank you so much for your
time today huge congratulations onk you
very
much